to Bangladesh now where supporters of
the main opposition party are rallying
in the capital Dhaka the latest
demonstrations are against a nine-year
jail sentence given to the son of former
prime minister khalidazier Raj police
have repeatedly cracked down on
anti-government protesters who are
demanding the resignation of prime
minister Sheikh Hasina and her
government let's bring in our
correspondent tanvir Chaudhry he is
joining us live from the capital another
Friday of protests there in Dhaka tanvir
tell us more about today's demand
yeah it's a series of protest movements
since last year now Traders protesting
mainly about the verdict handed out by a
DACA code against Tariq Rahman and his
wife zubaida Rahman who is the acting
sorry Grandma is the acting chairman of
the Bangladesh nationalist party and
happens to be also the Elder son of
former prime minister khalidazia now
this verdict took barely two weeks to of
preceding the code graph was actually
handed out in 2007 during the caretaker
Administration run by the military
government in those days Tariq Rahman
and his wife is in UK since 2008 and the
government says that this is the shows
that they're corrupt and this is out but
the opposition is saying this is totally
an orchestrated quote verdict it's
mainly a political verdict to retrain
them from participating in the election
so
the movement is continuous there's going
to be gaining more traction as the
opposition has been doing series of
movement since Wednesday after the body
there's been a protests all across the
country not by the main opposition party
only as well as smaller uh Affiliated
Alliance parties all across the country
okay so these opposition protests
gaining traction but they are facing
many challenges before the election next
year aren't they
yes very much so one of the main
challenges the uncompromising attitude
of the government now the frequently
come under attack by police even the
supporters of the ruling party there's a
limited gun for descent there's a
digital security law which prevents
people expressing themselves openly in
social media the newspapers and the
televisions are very restrained they go
on self-censorship because of this
digital security law frequently people
are arrested their homes are such the
protests are coming from out of the city
the hotels are such are interested
without Warren so this sort of
intimidation tactics is very common
trying to repress the movement before
the election there are nearly hundreds
of thousands of cases against opposition
members some of them were Anonymous
cases fictitious cases many are behind
the bars and the opposition one that
stopped there is also severe criticism
from the Western countries led by the
United States as well as Human Rights
Watch Amnesty International even I made
out a statement just a few days ago
criticizing the police Crackdown on
opposition so a lot of challenges ahead
but the traction is gaining momentum for
the opposition ahead of the election
thank you very much for that that's uh
Chelsea live in Dhaka thank you